hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's ignore my hair i slept with wet
hair and also your incessant cries for
me to play this game have moved me to
record this very early in the morning
i got a screwdriver i'm assuming that i
need that for this
oh
that's how i get out
well that was easy
uh oh
whoa
whoa what what what what what
that's probably not good
um
are you just gonna be there now
are you just there should i run i feel
oh i feel like i should run
no running would have been a bad idea my
cowardly hiding was the right strategy
so you're just uh hopping around there
huh
all right so my objective is clearly to
find freddy
where freddie is is a good question
i sure wish i could consult my map
oh
where is that
i don't know okay
freddy
freddy freddy freddy freddy that's still
my mission right
oh get to the atrium before
oh
help the rabbit ladies found me if you
get this message come to the roxy
raceway
second floor
i'm gonna build up some boxes so you can
hop over the construction fence and find
me
[Music]
what was that
i'm on my way
roxy raceway
i know where that is
okay
well if only it wasn't absolutely low
resolution this game is 80 gigabytes and
yet they couldn't spare a single
kilobyte for this map
all right that's completely unhelpful
i guess i'll just look with my eyes ah
roxy raceway
oh it's much faster than a map ah
what
uh what
uh
what why
are you having fun yet yes i am thank
you for asking are you having fun yet
was that you roxanne
i'm guessing i just got to go this way
but
there's patrols but they're not exactly
very patrolly
they just seem to be a
little sloppy
yes no yes no i don't know new slot old
slot i don't even know if there's an
option to pick a slot
it's not like it's shown me
all right um soda rhodiums
all right that's funny okay all right
okay
all right um piled up some boxes i think
you said that there was that you did
this
well this don't seem good
i don't know why they would do this
says the sound of like electricity going
on the fritz or is that an animatronic
kind of looking at me
i'm hearing something
okay
are those recharging porta-potties
very handy
definitely an electrical shock would
help things move i guess
what did i get
it's happening again why did you reopen
everyone remembers what happened to
those
kids does they
it seems like a place like this would
have a lot of customers so i don't know
why they would open it this big if they
didn't have people was i supposed to go
this way
again i don't really remember what
freddie was saying all i remember is the
important information of some boxes
being piled up
and that's it
maybe
no the other way is blocked off too no
it's got to be
it was right in front of me where that
save was of course that save was no the
safe was not there there was a bag there
that's not what i'm talking about there
was something else there
there's got to be a way to hippie to hop
over this stuff
right
maybe this is it am i dumb oh no the
dumbness it's creeping back into my
brain oh no
the secret is
it was inside my brain all along
all right boxes there's gotta be boxes
somewhere
what
oh
of course
this opens yes yes it's all coming
together now yes yes i didn't see the
signs at first
ah
okay
well now i'm gonna make progress i hope
seems to be oh a roxy balloon
and what exactly am i supposed to do
with these collectibles i know that
you're giving me collectibles but what
am i supposed to do with them
that's what i'm not understanding
oh
that's a problem
only a moderate problem apparently
level four well it's the wrong way
so somewhere in here there's a stack of
boxes
those clearly need level four as is
evident
and there's a stack of boxes somewhere
in here
that will get me
okay
where am i
oh
apparently i'm here
hi
okay
no
no no no
okay well i didn't like that
maybe later in the night when i get a
little stanky from running all
she'll be able to sneak away little
coward that's not what you said you said
i heard that
i don't know where you are
but i think i saw the stack of boxes she
was just right by them
okay stack of boxes clearly over there
this dude clearly over here but i can
come up right behind him
and jump up
nope
mission completed i used a stack of
boxing oh
freddy
freddy no i trust you
i trust you so much with my life oh
you're such a good animatronic
oh i'm sure that you're not evil you're
the only one that's naughty freddy are
you okay
there you are
i was so worried
i waited and waited for you
i missed the hourly recharge and i've
been trying to get down to parts and
service i think something is wrong
is there anything i can do
help me
get to parts and service
of course i will
how do we get there it is down under the
main stage
normally the stage lift takes me down
there after every concert
that is really the only way i know how
i'll
use that door behind me baby it will
take you to the rehearsal room on the
other side of the building
look for a backstage pass then find a
way to turn on the lift
good luck superstar
entering rest mo
okay
i'll do my best all right big papa so to
recap i was really paying attention
there i go through that door behind you
i look for a backstage pass in parts and
services in the rehearsal room
that's what i've gleaned from this
conversation and that's what i'm gonna
take with me but first i'm gonna look
for another collectible because who
knows when i'm gonna need another
balloon
and who knows what happens when i get oh
i knew it
ah that's not gonna last
something tells me that's gonna become a
pile of goop in my pocket but oh well
shove it down there with the shirt and
the balloon
i'm sure that no one's gonna be able to
find me with all this confetti dangling
off my back
oh a save point i'm sure that this isn't
ominous
and will be perfectly timed compared to
all the other safe spots all right thank
you
okay i need to get to the rehearsal room
find it backstage pass parks and
services
okay
are you lost no are you
can i hide in here no not in the pooper
is that animatronic only pooper do you
guys poop chica eats
what
just happened
okay
all right
didn't want to hear me talking anymore
about chica's bowel movements
it's a little rude
okay well it's very dark
what does a map say about this area
okay
nothing
something
something something okay so you're all
the way over there by that door i'm
assuming that's where i'm supposed to go
okay these guys
are not very
attentive
so long as i'm
whoa
okay
wall
good
okay
you can't hide forever which way you
come okay you're over there that's fine
okay i think you're stomping around in a
route over there i think this guy's
about to spin around the other side yeah
i think you're lupin
i'm willing to bet this door has like a
security badge
requirement
it's also blocked off so i'm just dumb
oh i saw my outline flash red for a
moment why would it do that
i think i must have to go through this
door here
because otherwise why would it say exit
on it it's not blocked
surely i can go through
no it's level four clearly
that was obvious okay well oh boy can i
run
i don't think she saw me the music was
toning down a bit before i got in here
so that means i'm safe
right that's how that works there's no
way in hell that you would ever find me
you are nothing great thanks appreciate
it
how's that narcissism coming along right
good good great
all right
so
seems safe so far i'm only assuming i'm
going in the right direction
oh hello you are here i guess
you coming this way
no you loop him back around
okay
so i can hide in that
i could hide in that
okay let me just point
oh no you went farther down okay
but you're gonna loop back and then when
you do
i'll be able to hop out of here
easy peasy
okay
well this is a little bit
dense but
yeah you turn around right there
right there buddy okay
i see what you got going on here i can
make it to this hidey hole if i need to
let's see if i can push it a little
farther oop yep hidey hole
quick
what about this door
it's a hidey hole
this is fine okay
now see this is what i thought they were
gonna do with this whole
thing in the last one but apparently not
oh oh god oh god oh god i got out too
soon i'm just gonna gun it now it's gun
time
hi bud
hey how are you doing no no no no
there's no need
but he said i can find a backstage pass
around here somewhere
yeah around here somewhere i gotta uh
worry about other things greg
uh greg you'd seem to not be cognizant
of the current situation
okay save point i'm gonna say i'm gonna
save cause that was a long way to go
that was a long ass way to go and if i
die then it's gonna be a real big
problem for me
so now that i'm saved i'm currently in
the rehearsal room don't know why
animatronics need a rehearsal room but
apparently they do
okay lock shooting script finalized
budget breakdown script permits
insurance prop list
freddy chica monty roxy like smoke
screen streamers lighting sure
whatever you say pal
does the back say special i saw a box
over there that might be it they're
always in those handy-dandy boxes they
would never just be lying around would
they
probably not
got it now we should be able to find the
lift controls lifty lou
and it's 12 30 for all that matters 2 30
for all i can read numbers
uh huh
i don't know if i'm to stage controls
i am supposed to be here
hey buddy
uh monty are you still raging
oh are you in here
oh no
monty
you okay buddy
how
you okay
oh what was the point of having two
doors i kind of go to the same place
okay
all right
is there a lift control here aha
that's handy dandy don't know why that
is
there's something else in here oh what's
this you're not worried about the alarm
gold looks old
what did you do
oh god it happened yeah okay
yeah i know i got a three security badge
now that's good i need that communicate
again
i think you fixed my signal
thank you i can see you on the monitor i
didn't think he could stand up consider
it a second
i see roxy and monty on the cameras oh
they're both coming to the office oh not
let them in the security doors are
equipped with electrical deterrence
hit the appropriate button okay what is
what is the appropriate button how do i
get out of here do you see the large
vent in the floor
you are probably standing right on top
of it if i can reach the room under you
i should be able to force it open and
let you out all the doors appear to be
on lockdown
look for me on the monitors if you see
me waving push the button in front of
the corresponding monitor to open the
door
okay
where
open the door
wait are you banging no
open the door the door
the
if i see you on i don't see you on any
of these monitors
okay all right okay now we're in the
classic five nights at freddy's mode
this is more like it
i can yes i can
no no no no no no none of that wait yes
go away
i don't even think about it
no
no green quickly
where are you
not seeing you aha
maybe if you weren't waving in the
darkness be a little easier for me
uh-huh over there yes
gotcha
oh
stop stop it stop
over here
over here is not very helpful stop stop
stop
gotcha okay thank you
oh
escape through the van is it yes no
hello
are you here
keep searching
let's get
stop stop stop
escape through the vent escape through
the vent
vents escape
ventscape
whoa hi
wow that's scary okay
all i found was this
disc thing follow me to the atrium
that is a program disc for the stage
show if you use it in the sound booth
you should be able to run a showtime
program which will activate the lift
you seem a little twitchy there freddy
also because of your twitchiness i was
paying attention to that not what you
said what did you say something about
the lift atrium maybe did you say atrium
atrium
you say tree
something about tree
it's like playing a game at telephone
with my brain as the intermediary and
there's like sticks six steps in between
me and a conscious thought
hey cool
man you're tall
why do they make you so big
ah
anyone else hear that ringing or is that
just me
okay all right
you know you really touted this whole
like hiding in your chest cavity to get
away from people think about my systems
go to the sound booth on the third floor
balcony run the performance program on
that disc then meet me back on the stage
please hurry
you do not have much time
it is almost the end of the hour or i
will wait here
okay you wait there
thanks buddy
thanks pal i kind of learned you can
just zip right past these guys
i'm assuming i go up the ski laters
i better avoid that spotlight what
spotlight i don't see oh that spot
okay apparently i didn't avoid the
spotlight the booth is on the third
floor
okay
why is uh why are there so many security
barriers now
yeah why are that my question exactly
why are there so many security barriers
now
how do i get up there
anybody want to tell me how i get up
there
oh hi roxy well that's interesting i bet
you don't even you don't see anything no
how do you see anything you don't you
don't how could you you couldn't there's
no way
uh
excuse me excuse
oh
excuse me
stupid idiot
you stupid dumb ugly idiot who is not
the best
you are in fact the worst
uh
well i'm kind of doing the hiding thing
so you're kind of wrong there
i don't know where she went i think she
might have gone downstairs
maybe yeah i think so
okay i'm just gonna gun it
apparently i'm supposed to go this way
maybe
where is that ah it's open over here
okay good so chica must be upstairs so
i'm gonna save you here
because it's letting me and therefore i
won't be a fool and not take advantage
of this
but also i'm real good at this game
might be the best
most handsome
best everyone's looking at me
being amazing at this game
it's a heavy burden being
at the top
heavy weighs the crown
fazbear noir fazbear noir is that lefty
ooh
hi how are you doing good to see you i
hate you
hi chica what are you doing there
being stupid don't turn around
oh oh my god oh well
well this is fun
hey
don't don't don't
no no no you won't find anything because
you don't know where i am you don't know
who i am you don't know anything about
me are you still there
nobody nobody wants candy candy's bad
for your teeth it's bad for your teeth
it's bad for your teeth
nope
nope i'ma say no
you don't know where i am
i did i did the running
you guys are too stupid to find me
because i am incredible
i'm outstanding
how do you see me you don't
you can't you won't you shouldn't
try it i didn't i won't
i can't assume okay
hello
your family is looking for you
yeah
that's great
interesting
so you're right there and you're not
moving did you get stuck
i think you got stuck
oh you're stuck behind the barrier you
idiot
you stupid fool
okay what was this
all right showtime disc
that's good i'm pretty sure this is
probably gonna be the wrong disc to play
i hope freddie's okay
i should get back to the stage right
away yeah let me take a look you still
there fredster oh he's still there
all right
so i have not saved i'm gonna cut it
[Music]
okay
easy as can be
it's an amazing song freddy i hope
you're singing loud and proud
saving easy peasy
eases to the pieces
the easiest peasy is oh my god what's
happening what is happening to me why
why why
what is happening oh hi chica hi okay
this is a problem okay there's a problem
there's a problem there's a problem
maybe i got a little too aggressive with
this
oh no they can't you never knew
you're the best
you will find him first
[Music]
something tells me you may not be the
best after all
you silly silly wolf
silly silly where are you
okay you're going downstairs which is a
problem because that's where i need to
go next but
if i go down the other side
i shan't have a problem
wow look at him go freddy you're really
not matching the energy of your uh
hologram
you really step it up a bit it's kind of
pathetic
oh well this is much easier to go around
this way
[Music]
oh wow look at them on their glory days
pretty cool i guess
all right hey
how you feeling buddy
well you couldn't press this button
great job superstar thanks just push
that button the lift will take us down
to parts and service
oh here comes vanity i better go
all right bye bunny
bye bun
hey
where are we going
oh no what time is it oh god that moon
thing's gonna get me there on the wall
quickly
get to the recharge station
follow me
okay well i haven't saved so uh you know
how i feel about that okay
no yeah yes no yes no yes you're right
but also shut up
shut up
i don't know about that i'm not 100 sure
about that
so uh do i get to do i'm sorry gregory
i am in no condition to carry you
okay well i guess i'm going in why am i
going in why am i in
what
well that seems a little illogical but
okay
um
can i have freddy back
can i get him back
oh
freddie
can you hear me freddie's in there i
have to get him out uh-huh what about
that thing
uh
got any words of wisdom about this greg
greggy boy
register
hi please take this map
take a map
okay thanks yeah okay i'll take the map
thank you appreciate that
thank you please enjoy i hate that thing
yeah me too buddy yeah me too buddy it's
a map of the utility tunnels
it looks like there's a security office
nearby
if i can find another security badge i
can get into parts and service
does it look like that to you because it
don't look like that to me
what do you see in here
i'm seeing dick and diddly
all right whatever get a security badge
from the warehouse office find a way
into parts and services
okay
thanks
thank you
thank you very much what was the point
of uh
me getting the level three i haven't
used it yet or maybe i have and i just
don't realize it
because apparently i need to get a level
four and uh
i just got the level three seems like
i'm getting these just before i need
them just after i need them actually it
would be the correct vernacular
okay this is fine
hello
uh heidi spot i guess
oh laggy spot too oh
okay
um oh
hey
how are you doing there's something here
hi
you're not a problem are you
you're not gonna be a problem you're
definitely uh i think you did
red light green light
oh
you
are an idiot i'm too good at this game
looking away oh oh
oh oh
okay so i need to get you past there
because i'm not gonna be able to slide
by am i i can't see anything i can't see
anything
oh there's nothing i can't see anything
well you're not moving you're boring
hey
i would think that yeah clomping
clomping seems about right
all right
easy peasy now
okay where am i going
ah pathetic lot
i wonder if there's a way around i
wonder i wonder if there's a way around
i just wonder
oh oh whoa whoa
hey hey no no
none of that needed
no thank you
stop are you still coming after me yeah
you better not
just for some reason you're a ven patrol
animatronic
so something to give me trouble i still
think those are cute another safe spot
well this is convenient
they're actually being nice about this
thank you
oh that's a trap that's a trap that's
definitely a trap this is a trap 100 100
percent of trap
apparently not what did i get
stolen property well somehow someone
broke into the rockstar road displays
case and stole the wind-up toy music man
prototypes the case was smashed and
there's glass on the floor but no sign
of a break-in nothing else seems to be
missing i have absolutely no idea how
they got into the building and there's
nothing on the security footage what
should i do should i call the police and
report a break-in vanessa maybe you
should do your job properly
vanessa
you know it's i don't know
i don't know if they're like being super
like overly
not subtle with the whole vanessa vanny
the bunny thing
seems pretty
seems too obvious
it therefore it can't be that what is
this
uh
yeah terrifying okay cool terrifying
very terrifying
horrifying
oh
uh huh
right
okay
well there's a lot of hiding spots so
i'm assuming that i'm gonna need to
hide from something which means that
something is going to come after me
that's just how that goes
what is that
is that a moon okay what
uh
that wall just moved
very good greg very good
oh so smart uh that one doesn't seem
like red light green light
which would be very strange because you
just trained me to do that okay it is it
is it is
okay
okay okay
oh
there's a button here
oh yeah oh yeah
oh come on you
where am i
push it there we go where'd it go oh
where are you going
i'm not over there
idiot so this is what you look like
inside
creepy
i like you better with your shell on
thanks greg
thank you very much
hey pal
okay pal
pals
par par party
party i'm guessing party
oh
hi
oh boy are you
okay that's weird
okay
party
oh hey pal
how you doing buddy
hey you just stay right there pal
oh man they don't like these guys
why did i
stop
stop stop stop stop what do i do stop
what do i do stop what do i do what do i
do stop
stop what do i do
what do i do stop
stop don't move don't move nobody move
nobody move nobody move nobody move stop
moving you're moving i hear you moving
stop moving stop it cease cease cease
stop
see send stop
push push push if this could push when
it's supposed to push
i would greatly appreciate it
okay there's something over here i don't
know why i didn't go in here first
oh boy oh that's a problem oh this is a
big big problem big big big
big bra
big profit oh why am i here oh why am i
here
why am i here this is bad idea oh god oh
god oh god oh god no no no no no no
great good hey how you doing good to see
you okay i'm gonna go this way now
stop stop
you're too fast stop
you're too fast
okay
oh god no no oh my god oh my god please
tell me there's nothing behind me okay
we're fine we're fine
go go now now it's time to go
okay
oh hey how you doing friends
i'm just gonna go
just going
pushing i'm pushing everything i can
oh
okay
oh what the freak was that
what did i just hear in my ear
what's over there what's over here
what's over here what is it security
office oh
should be one of those badge head things
in here yeah should be should be should
be also a lot of other things with heads
which is usually a problem
okay is there any collectible i'm
willing about that there's a collectible
here
somewhere in here
also it it did not
escape me that the previous present was
gold
you know what i mean
i don't know if that has any significant
meaning but
i did notice it and it had a nightmare
plush in it so who knows what that means
okay good oh
my god
okay okay okay okay okay this is a
problem this door is not open behind me
[Music]
oh it is open okay i thought it was not
open
oh my god what what where did you close
no you did not oh you did
stay safe safe oh my god so if they can
open them
no they can open it
i need to charge my flashlight but how
can i
no
oh my god oh my god no oh i can't
there's no way
okay i'll go without a flashlight that's
fine flashlights for nerds
i'm not a nerd i'm a cool guy
oh it's a dead end it's a daddy end
it's the deadest end
oh my god
oh my god where do i go where did we go
am i stupid am i stupid i am oh no don't
do that
okay
here i am not dumb
good
oh god stop stop stop get me up here
and i'm gone
yeah yeah i know i know you i know you i
know you're gonna be there i knew you
were gonna be there
it's fine it's fine a little bit of a
breather a little breather and then we
sprint again
okay
oh
god damn
that's the scariest part in this game
what the hell
i was out of left field
good god
oh
lag
yeah no i
i did not expect that i did hi map bot
how are you doing good to see you
you believe go to hell
you're the best
appreciate you
please explode
i'd really like it if you were no longer
moving
okay thank you bye i'm out of battery oh
yeah i get that i i know what that means
i i i've been doing that for a bit i
think there was a recharge station over
here somewhere
maybe no flies lies lies in slander
lies and slander
nothing
anyway i know i have a level four bad so
i can go that way and i'm there's
probably like a save right behind it but
i'm just making sure that
reset
i don't see a way to control it from
here
uh-huh okay
never do i
neither do i
i'm in
oh good
i found him earlier and locked him up
and lost him
that is great news he can be returned to
his parents he can't
turns out there's no record of him
how unfortunate
if you reattach my head i will go look
for him now his name is gregory
you know how i know that
his fab watch kept repeating it in your
voice
gregory are you there
gregory
vanessa but all the fast watches sound
like me it is the default voice option
good point
if you're part of this you're scrap
money will run the shows until person
service can slap your casing on the new
endo
hang out here for a while i gotta find
that kid vanessa do not leave me like
this
why uh why would you put monty your
judgment seems to be flawed also you
seem to have a lot of authority here
okay all right bye vanessa
anyway hero here i am so glad you are
here and alive yeah alive use the
console to let me out uh-huh okay i'm
gonna use the console to let you out i'm
definitely gonna do that just looking
around to see if there's a place to sit
fine it's fine
so uh what's all this really sterile
almost like prison like area
kind of creepy if you think about it if
you really think about it aha this is
what i was looking for
so
yeah i guess it all just does come down
to the endoskeletons in your programming
but whatever
it's not like this is the only freddy
everyone wants a time in the spotlight i
suppose
okay now that we're all set i can use
the machine to uh help fred a boy why
are there so many things here
and why are things like this why is
everything in a duffel bag that doesn't
make any sense okay chica upgrade don't
let her sing messes with the navigation
of the other bots horrible result when
she sang during live performances staff
bots dropped serving trays chaos guest
injuries 12 lawsuits experimental voice
box test failed a replacement advised
roxy sees things differently than the
others this upgrade was meant to help
her win races however there are some
side effects sometimes she will stare
and talk to the other bots through the
walls
montgomery's claw upgrades allow him to
play the base following performances he
uses mostly uses them to cause damage
defense repairs are getting costy
i think there's probably another way for
him to play base as in he doesn't
actually have to play it you ever think
about that
welcome to parts and service please
select your desired procedure
please enter the protective cylinder to
continue the protective cylinder
yes yes oh i know about it don't tell me
about it i've got so many protective
cylinders
i'm loaded with cylinders i'm
practically made of cylinders
i have it i'm just gonna go for a walk
because i'm tired
freddie you got anything to say about
that
a door with a zero perfect
oh
that is not as interesting as i thought
it was protective cylinder
could it be over here oh
the protective cylinder
no
10 huh
i guess i really shouldn't look at
what's in that box
oh level 10.
i'm just gonna bypass that
easy peasy
[Music]
no that's not a protective cylinder uh
maybe i could use it as a protective
cylinder
everything's a protective cylinder if
you
try hard enough
everything okay freddie do you know
anything about this protective cylinder
hello
the protective cylinder was here all
along maintenance i'm functioning much
more better now
grammar function error
perhaps i am still not at peak
performance could you not
reattach my head i don't know it looks
complicated just
reconnect the wires
and be careful
i am not quite myself at the moment in
case of an emergency the protective
cylinder will protect important service
personnel outside of the protective
cylinder deactivating animatronic safety
protocols now it is recommended that no
mistakes are made during the procedure
this is the protective cylinder
when you said enter the protective
cylinder i thought you meant to insert
it you meant me enter the protective
cylinder so that i am now perfectly
protected absolutely yes that's correct
hi
so when you say you're not quite
yourself
to reconnect freddie's head repeat the
correct sequence by pressing the
flashing connectors
[Music]
well that was easy good job
now use the testing console to run
diagnostics and complete the procedure
[Music]
oh boy
uh-huh
great diagnostics
[Music]
oh
what did i do wrong
what did i do wrong i did it perfectly
hi it's me again apparently i did not do
it perfectly but to show you exactly
what i did wrong i need to slow it down
about a thousand percent
and there you have it
come on did you miss it
let me zoom in for you
and it's right
there
apparently i missed the blue button by
about one pixel
i'm not blaming the game
i'm actually kind of impressed
what
didn't i all right here we go again i'm
really gonna nail it repeat the correct
sequence by pressing the flashing
connectors
[Music]
easy
easy okay easy good job
now use the testing console to run
diagnostics and complete the procedure
you got it
can do
[Music]
okay
good
okay finish by using the axis job freddy
is all patched up and ready for the big
show you may now exit the protective
cylinder what did i do wrong before
okay
[Music]
there's so much tech stuff in here
is there anything i can use to stop the
other bots bright lights in the eyes oh
nicely malfunction
i suppose a phaser blaster or a fast cam
could work where do i get one well you
can win a phaser blaster in phasorblast
fastcams are often confiscated in
montegolf but you will need a party pass
to open one of those attractions
chica normally gives them out for
birthdays check her green room in
rockstar row you may find one there use
the service elevators at the back of the
room they go up to rockstar row it looks
like they are all out of order except
for roxy's
okay good roxy's roxy's my favorite um
oh
anyway
you uh oh you're all good now well i
mean i don't really know if we need to
but i'm gonna go save now anyway but
thank you so much freddie check out
these pictures
chica has some sort of special voice box
roxy has new eyes
and monty was given better claws
we have to get these
we could upgrade you gregory
those parts belong to my friends i
i would never do anything to hurt them
what all they've done all night is try
to hurt me
they get what they deserve
there must be a good explanation
they are not capable of hurting a guest
none of us are
it would go against our programming
uh-huh yeah okay well tell that to me
and all the dead memes that happened in
the other universes that didn't be this
one
all right so i'm all out of time for
this episode but i gotta say
this is what i was waiting for like this
this part here with like the
animatronics with the red light green
light and then this sequence with what
just happened to freddie here that's
what i like expect out of five nights at
freddy's and like this felt
like it felt good like it felt great i'm
not gonna lie it was been pretty buggy
so far but this one actually felt clean
and put together and well well organized
so you know i'm i i kind of like it i
hope it gets i hope it continues like
this for the rest of the game because
this is very fun so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching check the
link in the description for more five
nights at freddy's that i have done in
the past and hey
this may be sold out but there's other
cool clothes that you can get over at
cloakbrand.com and check out my
distractible podcast with bob and wade
links are both in the description check
out bob's fridge for the episode of
distractible if you haven't listened to
that one already or any of them we
always have a good time we always have a
laugh so thank you and as always i will
see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]